is obviously a very difficult week for
policing again policing in the headlines
for all the wrong reasons and I think we
all are very shocked about the case of
David Carrick and I do just want to ask
you Mr cook some questions about what
seems to be the systematic failure of
the police system that allowed this man
to carry on as a police officer I was
reading he'd been in offices since 2001
he was known we understand as bastard
Dave because he was mean and cruel by
his colleagues he was known to three
police forces for allegations made
against him
he sailed through his vetting in 2017 he
was promoted to some of the uh to the I
think the Diplomatic and the
Parliamentary uh Protection Service
I just wondered Mr cook how how was this
man allowed to serve as a police officer
for so long
I think
it is quite clear that there have been
significant failures throughout this
um as you'll be aware in 2021 we did a
review of that in misogyny and
counter-corruption in forces across the
country on a thematic basis
and what we saw there actually resulted
in the most recommendations uh that we
have actually issued on an inspection
before 43 recommendations
both for policing the College of
policing in the home office which
have all been accepted and will all be
progressed
um obviously
the offense is committed by this
individual are absolutely despicable
and no individual should be allowed
anywhere near the police uniform
um who is that way inclined and policing
needs to get better
at rooting out these individuals earlier
as I say 40 recommendations made by
ourselves in relation to this
I think we must bear in mind as well and
hopefully a good police officer they're
doing a good job on a daily basis but
one officer like this absolutely slurs
the whole profession
and it will remain with the police for
some time because as we know it's not
the first issue in relation to officers
who have committed serious offenses and
not just in the metropolitan police
either this is a nationwide issue
so that culture that that culture that
is pervasive in some parts of policing
needs to be rooted out
police Chiefs need to take an
exceptionally strong line with it we
need to look at what we can do on a
wider police system basis in relation to
this certainly from an inspector
perspective we will be going back in
very quickly to force us to make sure
that those recommendations that we have
um
suggested a requested because we're an
inspector not not a regulator are being
completed I have to have confidence that
each Chief Constable will take that
seriously we'll do it quickly and not
just within time scales that we've set
but quicker than that because it's
important that the country can have good
confidence and Trust
influencing once again as we know it's
at the lowest level I can remember as a
police officer
and that was a 36 year at 36-year career
before I joined the inspectorate
so we do need to ensure that
please in quickly professionally takes
on these recommendations and does what
it needs to do to start rooting out and
preventing further officers and staff
like this from joining policing so we've
just been talking about David Carrick
but we know from previous the previous
session with the Metropolitan Police
Commissioner there's over 800 police
officers in the Met who are being
investigated for
um concerns about domestic abuse or
sexual assaults
800 that are being investigated in the
Met
it's a shocking statistic it is a
shocking statistic it doesn't mean all
800 obviously have committed some source
of offense but the investigations are
there
that is replicated across the country
not to that scale obviously but there
will be many more offices across the
country also being investigated by good
police officers and good police staff
who want to ensure that policing is
held to the highest standards that the
public quite rarely expect
I think just particularly around the
issue of women
and the way that the police force police
forces behave towards women both
internally between colleagues and how
they treat women as members of the
general public do you what is the
problem with the police service and
women
it's a very good question and look we
all know it's not every police officer
and we know there's 40 percent of Chief
constables now are females which you
think the systems at fault I mean it
seems to me I absolutely agree there are
many many police officers who do an
exceptionally good job and are committed
to serving the public but there is a
real problem isn't there with the
systems in the Police Service
I wouldn't say there's a problem
obviously the vetting approach in
relation to this the culture the culture
undoubtedly there are significant issues
with policing culture but misogyny is a
societal issue not just a police that's
no excuse it's no excuse I am not making
that I'm not making that an excuse I'm
just making the point that policing
obviously needs to be held to higher
standards than others because the powers
that police officers have
but policing is recruiting quickly from
the community it needs to make sure it's
recruited in the right people and we
know that's a problem that's an ongoing
problem and you're reporting at the end
of last year the vetting procedures the
recruitment procedures are not good
enough
can I just ask you very bluntly then do
you think that the police service is
institutionally sexist
no I don't and I think if we were if we
look at the fact that we now have more
female police officers than before
um
on the on the most recent intakes four
out of every 10 officers who were join
in are female officers
uh roughly 40 of the police and
establishment is female and 40 percent
of Chief constables are female so police
sin has come on Leaps and Bounds over
many many years in relation to this uh
institutionally misogynist no I don't
think it is is the significant issues in
parts of policing is the significant
issues with individuals in groups in
parts of policing then yes there is
okay because I'm just looking at your
report from the end of last year we are
left in no doubt that in too many places
a culture of misogyny sexism and
predatory behavior towards members of
the public and female police officers
and stuff still exists absolutely and we
did a survey of 11 000 officers and
staff and those results were shocking
um I think I think actually we should
call this for what it is and it's
actually institutional sexism I will say
that a significant issues in relation to
sexism and misogyny
okay
um and I also just wanted to ask you
um in when you came to give evidence to
us last March you you made a comment
that you didn't feel there was a problem
with police officers being able to come
forward and uh report colleagues who
were behaving in an unprofessional way
in a predatory way uh racist sexist
um you said that to us in March last
year now your report in the end of last
year says something very different that
there is a problem with officers coming
forward so do you now accept that is the
position my initial statement was based
on my own personal experience within
merseyside police because that was the
first time it appeared before the
committee as the chief HMI
um and
in my previous experience plenty of
officers have come forward most of the
the misconduct issues that occurred in
merseyside whereas a result of officers
coming forward and actually saying there
is an issue with this individual there's
an issue in how this individual is
behaving uh having seen some of the
issues around the country subsequently
um more needs to be done to ensure that
officers can feel safe in coming forward
that officers don't feel pressured not
to come forward and that policing is far
more open in its ability to actually
ensure that those are there is a problem
there is okay yeah I'm going to bring
Tim Lawton in at this point on that
point do you cover and if not should you
in more detail instances of whistlebling
because in my experience of looking
organizations you will ask them do you
have a whistleblowing um policy and they
say yes and then you ask them how many
cases you had and they'll say oh we've
only had two or three which to me is a
sign of weakness
so do we have a proper auditing of
constabineries to see how many
whistleblowing cases they they have the
level of severity and how they were
taken forward so that we've got some
conservatives which appear to have
hundreds and others appear to have just
tens then clearly something's wrong
because there won't be that much of a
difference in incidents happening from
one in the country to the to the other
how do you handle that
acknowledge every
police force in the country has a
confidential phone line for those who
wish to bring issues to the attention of
of
uh senior officers and police complaints
I don't have the figures available for
how many from each Force actually use
that or the number of whistleblowers but
I can certainly see if we do all that
information
you routinely collect that information I
don't know if routinely collect that
information or not I'll have to with
respect Mr it's slightly worrying then
for something that is a big issue you
don't know whether that's something that
you actually audit and over overseal bit
you haven't been there we audit and
oversee all police complaints
departments we look at counter
corruption and how well forces our DM
and counter corruption issues as part of
our binary approach to inspecting each
force and we look at various parts of
that
um to ensure that what police officers
are doing in those police complaints
department is professional is actually
making a difference for the public that
they serve
um as you will be aware decisions made
in relation to vessen on our last
vetting inspection we found one in five
investigations by police complaints
departments and decisions made were
inconsistent or we didn't agree with
them so that is in itself concern that's
20 of those investigations we could have
some more detailed information because I
think whistleblowing is an important
issue um uh here and
if you're going to restore confidence
people need to say know that if they're
going to whistleblade he's going to have
some impact so I think we'd like to see
some more information on that please
absolutely I'm going to move on to Diane
Abbott in one second but I wondered if
you could just give us your view about
the current status of a police
Constable's employment there's obviously
some concern about whether Chief
constables have the necessary powers to
remove officers from their position as a
police Constable we understand they are
different to a normal employment status
so could you just explain what that is
and what you think should happen police
constables aren't employees they hold a
different status than that the crown
servants so in relation to the
misconduct that goes alongside that it's
far more difficult to actually
dispense with an officer's Services than
it is for for every other employee what
goes alongside that obviously police
officers can't strike so there are other
benefits that that go alongside them
as we're all aware
um both the metropolitan police
commission others have
stated that the issue of having legally
qualified shares is causing a problem
and that the head of each organization
should be able to decide who should be
working in that organization so I know
the governments have said that there's
going to be a report commissioned in
relation to this it needs to be done
quickly in my view we need to very
quickly identify if there is a better
way of dealing with these issues the
statistics don't necessarily bear out
all the claims that are being made on
occasion so we do need to have a
definitive this is the situation this is
what we need to do I know there is
certainly uh police force around the
country sorry around the world where
officers have a different status such as
employee and I'm sure that is one part
of what will be looked at moving forward
and that's the internal review that the
Home Secretary talked about yesterday in
the chamber and do you know anything
further about that do you know about the
time scale or who's doing it I don't no
okay all right thank you very much Diane
Abbott
um
balancing priorities
but I just wanted to follow up briefly
on some of the points my chair raised
and in response to her questioning you
said that sexism is a societal problem
I can't think of a case where in The
Wider Society
somebody's been convicted of 24 cases of
rape are you sure you were saying that
there is nothing particular about
policemen and their attitude to issues
of gender are you sure
I can't speak for every police officer
obviously but certainly the vast vast
majority of police officers do not hold
that sort of view and approach
um so but we have seen plenty of serious
sexual offenses happening elsewhere it
is worse when it's a police officer I
fully accept that because police have
special powers police have a role in
society that that no officer should ever
ever be allowed to serve as a police
officer with this sort of mentality I
fully accept that what what I can't
accept is that every officer has that
mindset
carrot case that over 20 years nobody
ever thought there was anything that
they could report he was called bastard
Carrick that must have been for a reason
one of the Striking things is that there
was no one around him that saw that his
attitude to women was problematic and
his his senior officers promoted him
doesn't that speak to a culture in the
mat
this is obviously one issue on top of a
number of issues that we've seen with
the Metropolitan Police Force previously
why
this individual wasn't identified
earlier either by colleagues or by
senior officers or through systems and
I.T I really don't know and that's what
isn't it that's why he wasn't identified
we can point to plenty of officers
who've been identified by other officers
for wrongdoing for having the wrong
approach to policing so it's not
Universal
just last point on the carrot case you
were saying in response to my chair
trying to rebut this uh ijob
institutional sexism that you know if
your Christmas morning police officers
and
all the rest of it in my experience
very often in an organization which is
institutionally sexist or
institutionally racist in order to get
to the top of that organization you have
to internalize the culture so having
women Chief constables does not mean
that you cannot have a force which
remains institutionally success
I I accept your point and I think I've
already stated that I believe there are
significant issues with misogyny and
sexism that need to be rooted out by
policing as soon as possible
and uh finally on the very poor outcomes
for rape and sexual assault cases why do
you think the outcomes are so poor and
so slow
this is a significant issue for the
criminal justice system throughout not
just policing I think it is an absolute
I'll use the words disgrace that it
takes over 700 days for a report of rape
to actually just start a trial I mean
delayed Justice is no justice at times
the impact of that on victims is
absolutely wrong and the whole Criminal
Justice System needs to work together
to ensure that those delays are removed
and that victims do get proper Justice
and Swift Justice
conviction rates and prosecution rates
for that are so particularly low I mean
again this just feeds into my feeling
around the institutional sexism within
police forces I know you don't agree
with me on that but it is just
interesting when you look at the the
evidence uh anyway I'm going to come to
James Staley um can I support the chair
on that because and I think this is a
such a serious issue and when we talk
about figures in respective rape and
serious sexual offending there's a lot
of smoke and mirrors by everybody in
respect of this the major issue
um Regarding why cases do not get to
court is there's issues with delays is
because the police officers do not refer
especially rape allegations in any
significant number to the crown
prosecution service would you agree with
that that's where the major problem is
where we charge out rate of 1.5 for rape
I think
there are complex issues involved in
relation to
rape itself and the prosecution of rape
it is very much for the crown
prosecution service and policing to work
together to
vastly improve the number of Charges
going forward
I remember a time when the the actual
CPS and policing used to actually sit in
the same room and work together
which
made the issues of discussing difficult
cases far more easy than it is today
now I have seen I've worked with and my
staff on inspections I've seen people
are absolutely committed
to getting as many rapists before the
courts as possible
so I really don't think this is a
misogyny issue at all well can I just
say Mr cook that I actually think that
um I'm sorry to put this bluntly to you
you're a man who's always spent a lot of
time in you know you spent over 30 years
in the police force and some of your
answers here today appear to be not not
a impartial assessment to the police but
actually a defense of the police we're
asking you questions here 1.5 forget
about it if if what
um forces should be doing he's being sat
in the same room as a um as a lawyer
then it doesn't take a genius to work
that out and the fact that that's not
happening is outrageous I get back to my
point it is this the major issue
regarding matters getting to court is
that police officers are not referring
allegations of rape to the crown
prosecution service we have a charge out
rate of 1.5 percent in my view I've
looked for all sorts of reasons for this
I agree with the what the chair has just
said there has to be an attitude of
misogyny within the police force that is
allowing
um
all of these cases not to be prosecuted
that all these victims who are coming
forward are not even getting the chance
to have their case assessed by the crown
prosecution service and I just like to
know what your recommendation is what
you think we should do to change that
because let's blunt about it not all of
those cases are you know people are not
coming in and lying or not telling the
truth it is because the police are
taking a deliberate attitude to female
victims of crime
isn't it it's got to be you know look
I'm not being defensive about policing I
accept fully and I've accepted for some
time I just mentioned the words it's
disgrace has taken so long to get to
course and not enough people are being
prosecuted okay so this isn't about my
Independence or not this is about a very
complex issue that policemen are doing
the best in my view to improve it is not
happening quickly enough give you one
example operation ceteria is the
approach that's being taken in some
forces around the country as a pilot
being led by Avon Somerset where we are
seeing increased numbers of charges in
relation to rape as a result of focusing
on the offender changes in relation to
how rapes are investigated such as being
less intrusive for victims so victims
feel more comfortable going through the
whole process are essential and the way
it's done at the moment and what
policing needs to do to actually be as
intrusive as it is in relation to
victims in my view is quite clearly
wrong how do you think the police treat
vulnerable victims who come forward so
victims who may have substance
addictions may have made health issues
may have all sorts of challenges in
their life because those the people the
most vulnerable who are less likely to
get their case in court so not only do
we have a situation where
um in my view there is rampant misogyny
in the consideration of these matters
but secondly if you are vulnerable if
you have challenges if you need support
you are not going to get your case even
refer to the crown prosecution service
that's not true you're saying that's not
true and that's not happening oh I'll
refer you to my previous force that an
awful lot of work was done with the
specialized unit working with sex works
and drug users who were enforced in
sexual offenses and we're having good
success in relation to bringing those
cases forward so that happens that's not
just a merseyside police issue that's an
issue across the country is it as good
as it should be no but to say that no
sex worker no vulnerable person is going
to get the case to court just just isn't
true
tell me this Mr cook 1.5 charge out rate
what should the charge out rate be
I can't put a figure on what that charge
rate should maybe I know it should be
more than that we all know that victims
should be getting just as far more often
than the other than they are in relation
to to rape and serious sexual offenses
but I can't possibly put a number on
that
ask you one final question in respect of
the balance to be struck in resource
terms between
um
offenses of high homes such as rape and
the policing of other matters such as
theft and burglary what's your
assessment of how police forces
throughout the country are balancing
those responsibilities
I think it's always a difficult choice
where resources limited resources are
placed as we know demands increased on
policing I recently did a spotlight
report that identified that the outcome
rate for the likes of burgundy and
robbery were far too low
um the outcome rate overall for clamps
with the charge rates overall for Crime
uh was 15 in 2014 it's now five percent
so there's been significant reductions
in people being charged across all
different types of offenses
balancing those different difficult
decisions on a daily basis is for chief
constables and police and Crown
Commissioners to do
um what can't be denied is that
irrespective of what the offense is in
my view that charge rate is too low
okay the I mean I mean this is a very
pitiful State of Affairs and can I just
ask you to leave us with this
what is it that you are telling the
police or what is it that you are
recommending in terms of we talked about
rape and serious sexual offending but
other offenses what are you recommending
because it's either incompetence there's
got to be some reason for this
the public are being ill-served by their
police force at this moment in time
and so you are the inspector there must
be some recommendation you can tell me
now that's going to improve the
situation or is it just having a better
people who know what they're doing in
place
there are numerous issues in policing at
the moment as we were one is firstly
shortage detectives secondly there is a
very inexperienced Workforce and
experienced supervision let me give you
an example of that in 2014 10 of of
officers has under five years service in
2024 that'll be 38 so that experience
isn't as it was 10 years ago so there
are significant issues around police
tradecraft about experienced
professionalism about good Supervision
in relation to policing there's also the
issue of the twenty thousand uplift
which is a good thing for policing and
is welcomed by policing but that brings
its own challenges alongside that as
well we have made numerous
recommendations as I say 43 in relation
to this insignificant number of
recommendations in relation to rape but
there is no magic bullet for this
policing is at a time a very difficult
time a time of some would say crisis in
relation to its ability to ensure that
the public are kept as safe as we would
like them to be it is a difficult time
okay I'm I'm going to uh just bring in
Marco alongie very quickly and then I'm
coming to Simon fail two very brief
questions if I may very first is around
the 800 officers that are currently
being investigated are they currently
able to serve as police officers
I don't know the breakdown in numbers in
relation to how many are suspended how
many are on
um all the duties or kept from the
public I would be very alarmed if 800
officers are being investigated and we
don't know clearly what the outcome of
those investigations are going to be if
they're able to use their warrant card
if they're able to exercise their duties
as police officers as we speak that is a
frightening situation to be in so are
you not able to say whether they are I'm
not spending from Duty I'm not ducking
that question the commission the
Metropolitan Police has said there are
800 officers under investigation it's
under a thousand he actually said under
investigation
um how many of those are suspended and
how many of those are restricted uh is a
matter for the Metropolitan Police
Commissioner I don't have those figures
you will write we'll write to him and
ask yeah the second point was in
response to questions from the chair and
I believe also from the member for
Hackney which was around your response
to the point around misogyny if it's not
misogyny I mean we had Dame crested a
dick as the Met uh commissioner here in
London when a lot of these awful things
were happening is it just a question of
competence
and there's an element of lack of
experience and investigation on occasion
there'll be lack of competence are you
saying that
commissioner dick lacked experience no
which I think it's about the
investigations themselves not
commissioner did well if this is a
cultural thing and now systemic problems
uh we often say that culture and
systematic problems need to be addressed
as a question of leadership yes so are
we saying that leadership isn't
experienced
leadership
across policing there are some very good
leaders undoubtedly but leadership is
intrinsic on how competence and the
level of standards and values of that
force holds yes it might be previous but
it's still incompetent
uh you can still have yes you still have
experience and incompetence absolutely
okay Simon fell thank you chair um I'd
just like to touch on some of the future
challenges for policing if I may
um your predecessor highlighted that
economic crime is on the rise he
described fraud as having exploded
Russia recently come out with a report
saying that it's an epidemic Professor
Mark button has called it a tsunami lots
of exciting words there suggesting it's
getting worse and worse and worse
um
is it a high enough priority for the
police at the moment no fraud isn't high
enough priority I think we're all aware
forced to 50 of crime is fraud
one percent of officers are engaged on
dealing with fraud
um I don't believe it's an issue we're
able to investigate our way out of
without significant significant
resources being put in to fraud
investigation
so it is very much for me about how we
prevent it how we work with other parts
of
um both public and private sector to
actually prevent large parts of this
fraud and how we hold not just policing
but others to account for what is a
massive problem fully accepted uh our
police do enough around it no uh will
they say they don't have the resources
do much more about it yes
that is a matter for governments to
decide whether significant resource
should be put into the investigation of
fraud
what does good look like for you
good good looks like a significantly
less number of of frauds being reported
good looks like the organization of
those behind the fraudsters being
investigated much like citizen organized
crime much like county lines
because a lot of these frauds that we
see are of a type
uh good for me looks like a banking
system a financial system that does far
more than it does now to actually
prevent these issues happening uh and
good looks like those in charge of of of
tech companies such as your Google's
your Amazons Etc who are doing some good
work around this doing even more around
this to prevent those fraudsters
actually being allowed to use the
internet to do this
we have uh thank you we
have a wide range of organizations
operating in the fraud space at the
moment city of London Police is a lead
force uh Rockies around the country
action fraud and FIB public-private
Partnerships you've you've mentioned
already
but we also have a challenge that a lot
of the legislation in this space is
quite specialist
um and not all offices are trained up in
it understandably
to your mind is this a training and
skills issue or is it around the
structures
that we have to operate with currently
to deal with the problem I think the
conversation needs to be added on the
structures to deal with this I mean a
response officer who carrying a busy
workload is working three shifts is not
the right person to be carrying frauds
in this country it needs someone who's
got a better level of expertise than
that
I think we also need to look at the fact
that
a lot of the fraud issues are
exceptionally complex and are we
recruiting the right people to actually
deal with those types of frauds
um again the commissioner Mark Rowley
was a speech that he gave last week
mentioned the fact that he'd like to
recruit different people to be police
officers whether those recruited people
are police officers or not police
officers we certainly need to ensure
that we're getting people the different
skills to investigate some of these
difficult frauds as a country because
within policing people aren't
necessarily recruited with that sort of
mindset so we need to look at how we can
better capture people who
understand those systems better
it is a very difficult Market
because policing will not pay as much as
private Industries so a lot of the good
people who policing do take on after a
short period move into Private Industry
for far more money than they get within
policing so I know that the city of
London Police are working with tech
companies or financials institutions to
see if they can have some sort of
reciprocal approach to loaning staff
either way with different skills to come
and assist how police investigate but
I'll come back to the initial point the
scale is such that prevention not
investigation has got to make the
Forefront of this
I have to agree with you there just
looking at funding challenges which are
obviously quite
um difficult at the moment in the US
they have and and in other countries
they have the model where economic crime
agencies can hang on to some of the
funds they they caption reinvest that in
economic crime policing is that
something you're interested in I mean
policing does keep some money as part of
of
um
and seized assets Etc percentage of such
with CPS and others uh yes I think it is
an incentivization for policing to do
more around fraud I think we need to be
careful that they don't chase the money
as opposed to chasing what the biggest
risks and threats are that are in their
Force areas or in the NCA or in the
Rockies
thank you thank you chair thank you
Paula Barker thank you chair uh morning
Mr cook
um you were talking
um about in 2014 10 of officers
um had under five years experience and
you've said yourself that uh by 23 24
that's going to be around 38
um
given what you said about lack of
experience around standards and values
Etc
what impact do you believe that this
inexperience in the force is having on
the General Public
I think that an experience does have an
impact
when you have such a young Workforce and
quite a lot of when I say young it is
Young and inexperienced at times now
certainly with peqf and the the police
degree a lot of 18 year olds are joining
to go through that
uh I think it does have an impact I
think what it needs and what it requires
is good supervision on top of that very
strong standards and values implemented
by Chiefs and Commissioners to ensure
that both firstly people are properly
trained in relation to the role but just
as equally as being trained have that
ethics value standards drilled into them
from day one
um we look across the country and we see
some very good forces doing some very
good work
I'll raise the issue of homicide the
highest grades ever in a in a a
um an inspectorate inspection where
we've seen what can be done from a force
that in
2017 was engaged to a force that is now
the best performing force in the country
for me that is all about the culture
that's being instilled the standards
that have been instilled in the
leadership that's been shown throughout
the organization and others need to
replicate similarly why is that not
model but
we've got being replicated across the
country
that is is part of the role of the
inspectors and we are highlighting the
good work that's been done by uh
homicide to other forces and there are
other good forces as well who are doing
well but we have a force three Force
approach that is that is led by four
three different Chief constables four to
three different pccs working together
with those Chief constables
um so together with the College of
police and we need to ensure that good
practice is drilled home and since I've
become the Chief Inspector we are
focusing a lot more on the good practice
that policing needs to share better
disseminate and work in very very much
with the college to do so
do you think
um the police officers should have all
be working towards a degree would that
have any impact I don't think every
officer needs a degree
some of the best officers I've worked
with didn't have degrees
policing police officers need high
standards good values Common Sense
bravery compassion
they don't necessarily a degree on the
back of it it'd be nice for them to have
a degree but I think also on occasions
it stops other good people who might
consider creating policing if if a
degree was the only route so I'm pleased
that there is there's that dual route is
open still in relation to joining the
police
I'm sorry to labor the point I just want
to just go back to this
lack of experience and and I agree with
you about the degree issue and I think
you know you can have good standards
good values Common Sense Etc
the under-resolved thing of of police
forces could you know
we have lost police officers over the
years and I know there has been an
increase but you know in terms of the
net figures you know it's not quite
equalized what concerns me is that we've
got police officers and and you know
around 38 with under five years come
sort of next year yeah
how do we embed those good practices
those cultures what work is being
undertaking because I accept what you're
saying about someone besides and you
know models of good practice
but haven't really heard anything about
what's being done to embed those those
good practices and and those specific
cultures uh right across the country
really and that's that concerns me so
what is being done or what should be
done I think our role is to ensure that
mpcc and the College of police are doing
the right things to embed those cultures
and that's why we inspect in relation to
what they are seeking to achieve so if
we look at vorg we've got deficit of
course for Maggie buyers doing an awful
lot of good work in relation to ensuring
that the police approach to vorg is
better than it has been previously uh
with this the police race action plan
which is being progressed by mpcc
what is important from inspector
perspective is that what the police say
they are going to do to improve these
issues they're actually doing which is
why if I bring us back to the vet
inspection that we discussed we'll be
going back in shortly to ensure that
policing is progressing those in a
timely manner because it needs to so if
it's not we will further reports on that
in relation to it and
that will identify Chief constables who
maybe aren't pushing these issues as
strongly as they should be but we need
to ensure that good practice is
disseminated but we also need to ensure
an inspectorate that where we believe
forces are failing our chief constables
are fail in these respects that we bring
that's the Public's attention because
that's our role
it was a recommendation from the police
foundation strategic review that a
license to practice for police officers
should be reviewed every five years
what's your view on that
I didn't see more detail around the
actual mechanics of it
um I know other professions do have a
license to practice quite rightly I
think
police officer powers are such and
police have such additional powers to
the rest of society that instinctively I
think it may well be a good idea
that police officer should be regularly
tested that there should be regular
checks that the vet is being complete in
relation to them and that whole license
of practice can be extended into into
just more than just a sort of
annual appraisal that takes half an hour
and doesn't necessarily do anything I
think one of the issues that we need to
to be aware of is that
I've not looked at how successful it's
been in other professions but I'm a word
in this in a medicine and others that it
is part of what they do
uh so instinctively I think it's a good
idea but I need to see the detail
then touched obviously on nursing a
professional stance Etc
any room for policing to adopt a model
that would see
um I don't know you know similar to the
NHS where officers are on the front line
and then they refer to specialist teams
of colleagues in specific areas is there
any room for that and what's your views
yeah I mean The Apprentice specialist
teams around policing
um
that supports those response officers
because
Omni competence because policing is so
it's so complex now one big Omni
competencies is a bit of a thing of the
past well you know I'm really swinging a
Blue Lamp here but when I was a young
Bobby I mean it was about burglary theft
car crime domestic violence the
complexity now for police officers is
immense so
we all know how much time policing to
spends dealing with mental health which
it shouldn't be either one mental health
professionals today with one of my
family were in crisis it should be
someone else doing that so we can't
expect police officers to be experts on
every single thing they do so that
specialism is really important and where
we're seeing great successes in the
likes of rape and similar offenses is
when very specialist teams are dealing
with those so yes there needs to be a
front 24 hour 24 799 response but we
can't explain through how many
confidence of competence and they need
to have access to specialists at an
early stage
in relation to other advice or to take
in on the role of what they're doing do
we have currently the skills and
competence for officers to be able to
deliver all those things and if not
um then what can we do to ensure that
happens
I don't think officers these days can be
an expert in everything that they deal
with to deal with specialist areas on
specialist areas yes I mean you know
don't get me wrong the things like
digital forensics that not enough work
has been done there's another
Specialists deal in that part of
business
uh there is difficulties at times of
getting specially trained sexual offense
officers uh 24 7 who are up to date with
with what's going on and we've noticed
that in different forces that needs to
be sorted out as soon as possible
obviously
um but overall
the ability to go to a specialist today
with a complex problem is there whether
that's quick enough or not it's a
different matter
thank you
sorry why why do you think that not all
police forces have specialist sexual
assault
um officers and teams because that's one
of the recommendations we made from this
Committee in our report and I still do
not understand why some forces don't
just say absolutely this is a no-brainer
we should have this I
I think every Force do have specially
trained sexual offense officers not
every Force has actually had special
units for investigating rape and sexual
offenses absolutely I agree with you
it's the thing it's the right thing to
do you can't do anything about making
them
establish these units when inspector
make recommendations I can't force
achieve customers to render their
operational Independence
when everybody accepts this is the way
forward and operations
saying this is the way forward and the
home secretaries or previous home
secretaries have said this should happen
it just seems bizarre that police forces
don't have these units anyway Carolyn
Harris is there anything you'd like to
ask at this point no okay
um Tim are you anything you want to come
in can I just just some general
questions
um which is the best constabulary in the
country at the moment which is the worst
highest graded is uh I'm sad please
uh six outstandings as part of its its
nine categories
the force that's been in
engagements and special measures for the
longest is Cleveland
and has been for some time that has a
chief Constable new Chief constable in
place there he was doing some good work
and joining the team together and we're
seeing some
slow improvements in relation to that
Force as you know there are six forces
currently uh in enhanced engagements
with the inspectors
that's not because they are failing
throughout the force because of certain
issues that we are concerned about in
relations the way they are delivering
their business
okay so why is homicide the best in
Cleveland the worst
uh
to the numerous reasons in relation to
Cleveland I'll start with Cleveland
Cleveland has had too many Chief
constables over a short period of time
there's been a long history in relation
to corruption with a small sea uh both
public service and within that police
force it is a small constabury that is
underfunded it has Metropolitan problems
but basically a rural budget to support
that it has the highest Firearms crime
rates in the country one of the highest
violence rates
uh it is an area of significant
deprivation so more mental health issues
more people below the poverty line
um so there are a number of things that
come together to make that a difficult
Force plus it is what you're saying
because of the nature of the territory
it's inevitable that it's always going
to be it's not struggling it's not
inevitable it's under-resourced it's
underfunded in my view
it is also subject to uh because of its
location
it is not the number one
um
um promotion that police officers might
aspire to
so it does struggle to recruit uh senior
officers who want to work in that area
so there are a number of reasons for it
in relation to homicide why homicide
very good process of very good systems
very good leadership uh force that is on
on
um
totally on track with with what the
chief counselor wants them to do a force
that's been Innovative in relation to
its approach to a number of parts of
business for instance mental health uh
right person right care approach has
been adopted by the rest of the country
as we speak that's in relation to
ensuring that police officers aren't
tied up for significant periods of time
dealing with mental health issues or
dealing with NHS issues but can get back
to doing what they should be doing what
the public would expect them to do
um so throughout the force is well LED
it is it is it is resourced sufficiently
although the chief I'm sure would ask
for more resources uh and it's providing
a good service to the public of of
homicide you see what what surprised me
and I'm I represent the other end of the
country although my family come from um
homicide originally
there's a lot of difference between
homicide and and Cleveland I defer to
the chair ripped in front of the seats
there in terms of some of those factors
you've given for why Cleveland they're a
basket case because they're
environmental poverty
um social factors
there's no excuse for Cleveland to be at
the bottom and homicide to be at the top
in terms of what it's what it's dealing
with
and their excuses aren't they because
the reason Cleveland is a dud Force
number side is a good force is because
of the way they approach policing it's
not what they have to deal with the sort
of people they have to deal with the
social circumstances they have to deal
with because there are many other forces
up and down the country who are doing a
really good job in challenging areas
but they don't use as an excuse we've
got a challenging Cleon tell that we
have to look after frankly so I'm more
interested Mr Mr cookers to why of the
police's own making are they failing in
Cleveland uh and succeeding in in the
homicide you've mentioned leadership and
continuity of leadership is is clearly a
key factor what's he gonna take and what
do you think your role as Inspector is
to turn Cleveland into a homicide
uh
it's a very good question I'll answer it
and say it's not one reason why
Cleveland is failing it is a number of
reasons that leadership is exceptionally
important and we've seen what good
leadership can do in homicide uh the
problems in homicide and Cleveland are
similar the resources in homicide is
more than Cleveland
um
we need to ensure that the right people
are encouraged to go and work in
Cleveland that I know of a lot of good
police officers at all levels who are
working in Cleveland at the moment and
doing a good job despite the issues that
they face uh the new Chief Constable
will do well he can to improve that
force and the home office are currently
working with Cleveland to identify if
there is a solution to other resourcing
or funding that they can come to so the
whole of the police in sect and
including College of police and mpcc are
supporting Cleveland
um the progress has been very slow as I
mentioned I think it's seven Chief
constables over a very short period of
time which
obviously the lack of continuity for the
staff is a real issue
um so Cleveland doesn't need to get
better undoubtedly uh will it reach a
homicide level of of good
not without further resourcing in my
view yeah I'm in terms of what you think
your view in all of this is when I was
children so I was responsible for John
Services departments who were inspected
by uh by ofsted and some of them would
would fail and some of them would be
good or outstanding or whatever one of
the approaches we took is where you had
outstanding authorities we would suggest
they seconded some of their offices and
in some case did a mentoring between
political leadership as as well to those
failing authorities to find out what
they're doing well there and how they
might apply it to the failing Authority
what happens for police constabulary is
and do you have a role as the inspector
to say you need to set up some sort of
mentoring partnership program so that
the the Stardust of humbicide can rub
off on Cleveland or whatever it might be
Mr Lawton we've done all of that I have
no power to Second officers any word
across the country that is that each
police force is independent the National
Police Chiefs Council can't make a chief
a senior officer move to a different
constabulary maybe that's what should be
able to happen I might happen to agree
with you I think that we should be
parachuting good people in to some of
the areas that are struggling but I have
no power to do so I've suggested that
previously I've worked closely with the
home office in relation to it and
solutions for this you made that
recommendation one of your own reports
no I'm gonna have to complete an annual
report yet okay will you make that
recommendation in your next annual
report as part of annual report I will
be reporting on how I think what we need
to do to improve those forces who are
not uh or are currently in engage and
are not necessarily in a position to
Aspire to adequate good or outstanding
but will you suggest this as a as a
proposal given that you understand that
agree with it I think the inspectorates
should have more power in relation to
what it can do I think this should be
the opportunity for police officers to
be moved to different parts of the
country where that requirement is or
even there should be some consideration
in relation to what we do with local
authorities of a sort of
commissionership approach on occasion if
that's required but
we can't allow forces like Cleveland to
be engaged for five years now I think it
is that is too long
um everything that's a yes but yes
you'll consider it I'll show me consider
it yes and it's it's a conversation that
I've had previously
I recall them Chief Constable of
homicide did go off to Cleveland for a
period of time I don't know if that was
just a relationship between the two
forces the relationship between two
forces it was it was he
basically said yes I will go for a short
period of time to the new Chiefs in
place and he then was responsible for
being in charge of two forces that was
just them deciding to do that he did
that out of out of goodness of heart as
opposed to anything else well there we
have a lot of goodness of heart in the
homicide anyway yes you do when you're a
very good police force as well a very
good plea yes considering where it's
come from where it is today it's made
remarkable progress yes absolutely and I
should pay tribute to the chief
Constable
um I'm going to say Carolyn Harris
because she hasn't spoken yet and then
Marco I think you might have any
questions
so I just wanted to follow one from the
the Cleveland conversation and ask you
talked about it when you've actually
implemented some like the graveyard of
fleece ambition
um how much influence would the PCC have
on the structure and and encouraging a
change because they are a consistent
is it
yeah the the the current PCC is doing
his best in relation to attracting
people in
um there's no Financial incentive is one
of the key issues because they can't pay
someone more because it's a really
difficult place to work under the police
regulations so that's
um
it is the same Revenue work for an
assistant chief Constable basically you
are on the same rate of pay unless you
get London allowance so
it is more attractive to work for many
people in a force that is not so
challenging as Cleveland so they do
struggle to attract people in
I wouldn't call it a graveyard just for
just for clarity but it is a
significantly difficult policing
environment
um at the moment
were there any questions you'd like to
ask we're just about to finish I think
too yes well I wanted to bottom out a
little bit more the whole issue around
behavior and and culture
um in your recent inspection on vetting
and culture found that women were
fearful of reporting colleagues with
offices and stuff experienced British or
improper Behavior saying that this was
rarely challenged
what I find is also very rarely
challenged is women who have been abused
who are not getting the service they
should be getting from the police force
and when they do come forward they're
the ones that are being made to feel
guilty
so when they're coming to a force that
is actually meant to be supporting them
they are inevitably finding themselves
an even more uh difficult situations
so what is it that needs to change
and how confident are you that things
will change
I think in relation to internally
um
female officers coming forward need to
be reassured that senior officers will
actually take the right action in
relation to their complaints and as
we've said previously on our vassal
inspection we did see that
not all the decisions that have been
made in relation to misconduct
were satisfactory so there needs to be a
far stronger approach to supporting both
female officers and staff internally in
relation to this externally
I agree with you victims should always
be the priority for policing
that keeping victims informed that
ensuring that the right people with the
right skills are and the right
compassion are looking after these
individuals is exceptionally important
can I come in on this I'm sorry because
we all know what needs to happen we all
know what should happen and you're
basically saying uh yes you're right
this shouldn't happen and this should
change but my question is what needs to
happen for that change to take place
they change in behavior and how
confident are you in that happening we
know what needs to happen
how will it happen and how confident are
you we need to continue to inspect
police forces to ensure that Chief
Constable senior officers are doing the
right things to ensure that culture
changes that people are taken seriously
that the right systems are in place
right across the country in relation to
how to find those people both internally
and externally who are committing these
offenses against either colleagues or
members of the public
we will continue to do that as an
inspector it's am I confident
it will improve yes I'm confident it
will improve
um we need to ensure as an inspector
we're doing all we can together with
others across the police and system that
that Improvement is quick and does not
take years and years
okay
thank you very much can can I just ask
you um just a couple of very quick
questions uh there seems to be some
speculation in the Press about whether
those officers who were involved in the
vetting or saw events during the course
of
um uh David carrick's career at the
Metropolitan Police and didn't report or
allowed the vetting process to just go
through and allow him to carry on there
seems to be some speculation about
whether those officers should be brought
to task what do you think about that
without knowing the exact details
Journey it'd be really difficult to
comment on that that is a master for the
Metropolitan Police Commissioner
um and as I say without without knowing
more about the exact situations in
relation to what on those nine occasions
brought this individual to light it
would be wrong for me to comment but you
think it's something that should be
looked up
there are those who commission fans and
those who allow others to commit
offenses knowingly
I think it's I am no doubt this will be
part of what's uh lady Angelini looks at
as part of the review that she's going
to do in relation to this right okay and
I just also wanted to ask you about the
inexperience of the Police Service going
forward and you talked about the quite
striking numbers over 30 percent yes
of of people with less than five years
service so could you just how did we
manage to get ourselves into this
position that we we seem to have lost so
much experience and knowledge within the
police and we're ending up with a very
large chunk of officers with limited
experience so
just tell me how how have we ended up in
this position and this starting point
2010 austerity and the reduction in
significant reduction in police officer
numbers
now trying to get back to those those
police officer numbers obviously is an
issue I would add on top of that that
police officers in real terms as police
Constable uh have basically had a 20 pay
cut since 2010 to what they compared to
what they earn now so policing is not a
vastly attractive proposition for a lot
of people particularly in areas where
there's a High Cost of Living
uh add on to the fact that the respect
that people have for police over the
last few years has diminished add on to
the fact that in Private Industry people
are playing more for police officers for
instance train drivers get significantly
more than police constables and that has
become a fair profession for a number of
metropolitan police officers Etc
um so it is a very difficult time to
recruit and retain police officers of
sufficient standard to ensure that the
public are kept safe and that's an issue
for all of us across the system it's an
issue for government we need to be
paying very close attention to this
because that 38 percent next year
if and we are getting more experienced
officers leaving not just younger
officers the retention of young and
Senior officers is a concern
so it's something we should all be
concerned about so when I was younger of
joining the police was seen as a career
that you do for 30 years that was what
you were going to spend your life doing
so that's that's not how it is for
people now no but even even on that
point I mean you know when you join the
police when I joined the police I didn't
do it because anyone 30 years I got a
pension a lot of police officers during
because they feel they have a vocation
for policing that they want to make a
difference with the public they want to
be public servants
um but the pension Arrangements have
changed in relation anyway so you know
if you if you decide you're going to
join as a police officer it's a totally
different pension Arrangement now
um
but
at the moment confidence and Trust in
policing as
is at such an extent that
why would you want to be a police
officer
you've got to have a real vocation
to be a police officer to be a police
officer but particularly as I've
mentioned the other issues that go
alongside that and that concerns me
greatly because I want the best people
possible protecting not just my family
but families across England and Wales
okay thank you very much for your
appearance before us today I'm I'm
looking forward to the next time uh
you're in front of us I'm sure we'll see
what happens with policing and the very
sad situation it's seen currently and
and let's hope there's Improvement but
thank you very much this morning for
your time thank you thank you
foreign
this is our second panel I'm going to
ask you to introduce yourselves to the
to the committee would you like to start
Steve good morning Stephen Hartson I'm
currently the chair of the police
Federation from England and Wales thank
you good morning I'm Harvey katkar the
vice president of the police
superintendents Association thank you
very much and um you're very welcome you
I think you were sitting at the back of
the room during that first session with
the Chief Inspector I'd like to start
off really by asking both of you about
the current situation in policing and
obviously this week the really Dreadful
news about David Carrick as a serving
metropolitan police officer until just
yesterday
and
um my view that we have to recognize
that the police service is
institutionally sexist
I just wondered
if we could just have a little bit of
quiet
in the room Diane
Diane could we sorry thank you
thank you
so I was just asking about your if you
could give me your view really on on the
situation as you see it I don't know
which one of you wants to start
we're happy to start first thank you
um I guess my starting point is as a
police officer to hear what's happened
this week is horrific and it makes me
feel sick if I'm being honest I have
29-year service in policing and I you
know I feel that we've let the victims
down and I'm really sorry as a service
that we have done that I don't think
there's any police officer that wouldn't
find that abhorrent in terms of what's
happened and we really need to get to
the bottom and make sure we root out any
officer that has those kind of views and
commits those horrific crimes
um
you ask the question at the start do we
think it's institutionally sexy sexist
as a service
um based on my level of service I think
there is an issue in policing and it
isn't necessarily confined just to the
Metropolitan Police
we also have to recognize that it isn't
restricted to certain ranks and we have
to definitely understand that but my
view also is that we have a number of
really good officers at every level that
come to work every day as Mr cook has
referred to that want to do a good job
for their communities for their fellow
colleagues that they work in and you
won't want to stand up and make sure
that when victims and Witnesses both
internally and from communities report
this that they are able to be supported
and we root them out
and I think we all accept there are many
many officers who are doing a very good
job as police officers keeping us all
safe I guess do you think the system is
it systematic the the problems rather
than individuals is it the system that's
failing and wrapped around that the
culture
so my view would be there are two areas
um in relation to this the first is
around the culture and that we need to
make sure that we create that
psychological safety
for people to be able to come forward
and certainly from an internal
perspective that we allow and listen to
people's lived experiences and based on
those lived experiences we are looking
at our systems and processes to see are
they fit for purpose to allow people to
come forward we then need to look at
whole system review of all of our
processes we've we've talked earlier on
about the recruitment the selection the
vetting process the misconduct and just
make sure that all of those are robust
people have the right training that are
investigating those areas of business
and crimes and that we are also timely
because you know it's under acceptable
that people have to wait a significant
amount of time and particularly for
victims from community that are coming
forward that we have the right processes
and the right support we have the right
training and that our offices are
skilled
and show that empathy you know the
victims are believed that we carry out
thorough investigation and our internal
processes are robust but also and I
think some more rarely referred to this
previous committee that we don't have
biases in our decision making
we do at the moment
I think Mark Smart Riley referred to
that there have been instances certainly
within obviously he makes reference to
the Metropolitan Police where some of
those have disproportionately impacted
on individuals
talking about say leniency within
misconduct hearings that certain
officers would be treated more leanly
than others I think it's about that
consistency we need to make sure all the
decision making is reversed it's
transparent and there is clear rationale
for why decisions have been made but
equally when we are
you know in terms of sanctions as you
refer to it that they are both
transparent and proportioned and there
is consistency across all forces it's
not just particular to enforce that that
is across all 43 forces
okay
good morning if I might Echo the
sentiment from Harvey as well and offer
an apology to the victims but also to
The Wider public for the loss of
competence and policing
um that's on behalf of every right
thinking decent police officer that is
actually appalled by recent events and I
just think it's incumbent together on
the record now because we are absolutely
disgusted by what has happened and
certainly within the police Federation
in Wales we'll be pushing for the
changes that are needed to try and
rectify that to get back the confidence
is so definitely needed
um by yourselves but also the wider
public
and what are those changes
I think initially you've got to look at
leadership it was already commented on
previously that leadership starts at the
top
um
we talk about culture there does need to
be cultural change there needs to be a
proper victim-led approach that when
somebody comes forward as a police
officer but also a member of the public
they are supported properly because the
difference I suppose if you look at
public crime is that a victim
May reporter crime and they might not
know what I have to work with that
person whereas if you report on offense
against a colleague that's in the same
environment so there might be elements
of having to work together on the same
team and that causes immense pressures
probably more so in rural areas but not
it's not not alien to the Metropolitan
environments as well because policing is
a team it's a family in itself and
people will make comments advised it is
incredibly difficult from dealing with
you know police officer that come to me
for representations report to stand up
and be counted quite often they say I
just want this to go away and to stop
obviously we then want to make sure that
that behavior is stopped properly and
part of the issues that we're trying to
find and do away with now is whenever we
take um a chief Constable to an
employment tribunal we don't want any
cop threes or a non-disclosure order
imposed we want it to be an open and
transparent process so that if we have
won the case and the person the officer
we represent is okay with having their
name out there they can say this is the
type of behavior that we reported we've
challenged it we've sadly had to take it
to an employment Tribunal we have one
that is the kind of culture we need to
stop because if you shine a light on
this Behavior it will stop there should
be no hard in place for it whatsoever
and it's more about the victim-led
approach for police officers in
particular to say come forward challenge
it be supported properly can we assist
them with move them a different team
different location but also to make sure
that the perpetrators are dealt with
properly but how do you you have to be
fair within the process because you
can't have vexatious allegations it's
about safeguarding the process for
everybody but obviously when you get
patterns of behavior if two or three
people said the same thing and you've
proven their significantly independent
that would raise alarm Bell for me so
you can perhaps do more that way bearing
in mind the victim so just going back to
the non-disclosure agreements so those
are where no you're not allowed to say
what's happened I mean this we've we've
had this around women who um settle
claims and employment tribunals around
sexual harassment and and then nobody
knows so you're saying that the police
use non-disclosure agreements stop it
being public what's gone on in terms of
allegations and findings around
poor Behavior assault sexual harassment
is that what you're saying they use them
for a variety of reasons it's probably
more prevalent in the private sector
where again you take you take policing
where because your report and allegation
to go to your Chief Constable you have
to remain in their employment normally
to continue and that's a significant
pressure on our members to have to take
a chief Constable to court you know
there's internal pressure is that about
why you're saying that why are you doing
it what you want to rock the boat for
whereas in the private sector you'll
take an employer to court because you've
left and you're not happy so you can
walk away from it
if they're imposed then we as a starting
point it was this year sorry late last
year we decided that we don't want these
cop threes as the term now from the
employment tribunal service they do away
with them as long as the victim's happy
because they've got to put their name to
that and then there's the potential
stigma supposed for whatever better word
that so you've taken your teeth to task
over something which people might say
isn't appropriate but that lived
experience that victim is huge and to
challenge a police service to take it to
task is an immense Undertaker for
anybody you know it takes a lot for a
victim of a serious sexual assault to go
to court knowing the way that Barris has
potentially treat them in doing their
job to highlight the deficiency in their
evidence it's equal as difficult for a
police officer an ET to take their Chief
to court knowing if they win they remain
in their employment and what does that
look like is the secondary description
uh sorry secondary discrimination
so um we did some press work a little
while ago and I said you know cop 3 is
all in existence these non-disclosure
orders are prevalent in the industry in
policing and a an mpcc spokesman unnamed
said no they're not
um there are and we've done an Foy to
try and find out the scale of them so we
can understand it in a far better way to
say look stop we don't need them we need
to call out the inappropriate action the
behavior of other people be it um the
same rankers myself or hire officers to
see what the culture looks like because
then once you can understand that you
can deal with it
if I may ask you and you have um a very
impressive biography
um and given what we've heard today
about the potential of institutional
sexism and and I agree with the chair I
think there is institutional sexism
within the police sadly but um
as I said you're very impressive
biography uh the first female
superintendent Tactical Firearms
Commander public order bronze commander
in your Falls you are a woman of color
um what's your experience been because I
think you said you've got 29 years
experience what's your experience as a
woman been within the police force over
those 29 years so thank you first of all
commenting on my bio
um I'm sad to say that I have
experienced sexism in my 29 years but
what I would say is that there have also
been some positive steps towards trying
to remove that and I absolutely get that
we're still not there and there is still
a long way to go and it goes back to
what I've said at the start that you
absolutely need to create that
psychological safety to enable certainly
internally for women to come forward and
feel that they can make those statements
and allegations and that they all listen
to and that is so important and I think
you know being the first in so many
roles there is so much pressure in terms
of that role modeling which I think is
so important as well and particularly as
a senior leader that you ensure that you
are creating that you are increasing
your colleagues cultural competence in
terms of knowledge and awareness because
it is so easy sometimes not to
necessarily fully empathize and
understand some of the challenges that
particularly underrepresented groups May
face if you're not from one of those
particular groups that's not to say that
you don't have empathy but it beca it
can or make become more difficult so I
think it is about having the courage and
I think sometimes I also recognize that
it is far easier for someone who has
rank to actually stand up and you know
make your voice heard so we also have to
recognize that because we are in a
culture which there is a hierarchy
um and you know it's been really
positive to hear some you know the
things that come out from both Sir Mark
Rowley about you know the the
confidential hotline that people can go
to so I think we have to look at as I
say the various methods having listened
to those lived experiences where people
can come forward and then we have to
have the right systems and processes
that enable issues to be investigated
whether that's misconduct or a criminal
matter and then there needs to be that
ongoing support through the criminal
justice system so um you know I I think
all of those are equally important you
will have heard sort of towards the
latter end of the first session about
sharing good practice and obviously
there's no compulsion for officers to
move across this and share that good
practice
but are you called upon given how
impressive your your CV is are you
called upon to share that good practice
and to support or Mentor Women Within
other forces and and how can how can
that sort of
um
be widely shared because obviously you
know there's only one of you
um but how can we get that that good
practice shared out a bit more
so there are a number of other fellow
colleagues within the service and you
know we the there is a number of
coaching and mentoring schemes both that
as an association we currently are
running the future supers program which
is aimed at underrepresented groups from
inspector and Chief Inspector rank
because we also recognize as an
association we are that pipeline to
chief officer group we know a lot more
still needs to be done to get the true
diversity amongst all the ranks
particularly senior officer level so
that is happening it happens with
working with the college so as an
association we work very closely with
colleagues at the mpcc the College of
policing my colleague here Steve to make
sure and Mr Cook's Department to make
sure as you say those areas of good
practice are promulgated amongst all
forces but what I do know from our
membership is that sometimes there is
that lack of consistency and that is
something we definitely need to get
better at in policing so the college who
set the standards and then hmic the
inspector get amongst against those
standards and outcomes there is
consistency amongst all forces thank you
thanks Joe
thank you Chad um I'm going to come on
to pleasing prioritize a minute but can
I come back to a comment you may just
now Mr hartsman about the
the Carrick situation you said quite
rightly that there are all right-minded
police officers are discussed it and um
outraged by these um these Revelations
trouble is they went on in this case for
17 years
there was a culture of cover-up
given his nickname and everything else
that seemed to go about him
that nobody seems to have blown the
whistle or if they did nobody took it uh
seriously and that his colleagues were
content to continue to work with
somebody
of that
bad character as it now now turns out
so I'm more concerned as I've raised
yesterday with the Home Secretary not so
much about this individual and the
render things he's done but the people
around him that allowed that to continue
so
where is the mindset problem that needs
to be addressed and how are your members
proactively addressing it
first to protect the investigation I
don't know the full details of of who or
how many people may or may not have
reported his action in the past I'm Keen
to understand it I'd love to see the
detailed reports that have gone on so
far in terms of asking my members
what they can do we encourage them to
stand up to stick to police codes of
conduct that if you see inappropriate
behavior it's incumbent on you to report
it immediately it's unequivocal it's
what it says the first action is to go
to supervisor to document it once you've
done that you've fulfilled your duty
however if you see it you should
continue to report it
I think the difficulty is once you
report something you're not always kept
in the loop in the investigation because
certain things you might say something
now it gets reported on and you'll be
forgotten about for maybe six to 12
months because they're progressing the
investigation they might have come back
to you they might be asking other areas
um other colleagues to see what that's
like it comes down to supervision that
if you know something is taking place
inappropriate it needs to be dealt with
immediately you can't let it continue we
do have a problem with Supervision in
the Police Service as a whole we've
already talked about the attrition rates
we don't have in my opinion a high level
of supervision if you look at sort of
standard policing response policing
compared to specialist policing was on
the Firearms team so you had a higher
level of supervision on there to make
sure that you conduct yourself properly
and professionally but because the level
of responsibility you had the proper
oversight
if you look at some teams you know you
might have 20 30 pieces just one
Sergeant on the team that's not good
enough you need proper effective
supervision so that someone at any point
can call out inappropriate behavior feel
supported by the supervisor and then
have the support of their team to go
you've done the right thing I don't
think that's always in place
um we look at the the entry requirements
coming into policing now with the degree
route and you would hope that if you
have a higher qualified higher educated
person to come in they will feel more
empowered to do with that that doesn't
appear to be the case at the moment so
I'm Keen to see what more has been done
on the ethics and morality when they
come into policing but it's about
encouraging the environment for people
to actually step forward and make the
allegations that that all sounds
fine but it's not working in practice
and clearly it doesn't work in practice
here hence me raising with Mr cook about
the whistleblowing processes and how
well they work or not and it was
slightly concerning that he wasn't
really aware of how they do work and
where they work effectively or not
are you confident that the whistle
playing
um systems within constabulous are
sufficient effective and are actually
working and if not why not what needs to
be done
I have concerns about the whistleblown
process in itself because to get to the
stage of whistleblowing it's making a
protected legal disclosure so you can't
just technically go I'm not happy and go
out to the press or to your local MP
you're supposed to follow the stage
approach to make that complaint known it
might be that some forces have low
incidents of whistlebrown because
they've got a really good
pre-whissel blown policy where you feel
that you can go and Report something
effectively to a supervisor it's then
progressed by Professional Standards and
it might be some force that there aren't
and for me as a federation when people
come forward to make a what they want to
say I need to go and say this up because
not being listened to we have to follow
the process legally to get there to
protect them and their status so from
what I know every Force has a
whistleblown policy I've not done a
compare and contrast across the country
to see how effective they are and I
would like to see some figures to
understand I think you mentioned two
percent uh in one in one force to a
higher another Force I'd like to
understand what is a prevalence
complaint set against the whistleblowing
policy to see has it been dealt with
effectively and do they have lower
complaints in certain aspects of
misconduct compared to others has the
Federation done any work on this do you
think it's something the Federation
should be looking at more it's something
that I'll take back to my board and my
last can we look at whistleblowing we
have a very effective equality board
within the police Federation of England
and Wales and it's something we can look
at to find out because part of the work
we did around the non-disclosure orders
came from the from the equality
because I knew we I think it would be
useful if the inspector got there's
great a much more transparency around
where there do appear to be disparities
and it and it is as you say linked into
if they've got effective complaint
processes simply working then again
let's look at some of the numbers there
but if you've got few complaints being
made in that that process should happen
and few whistlebling
um uh events take place I think clearly
there's a there is a problem
with internally we use a What's called
the grievance procedure and it's a it
could be popular known as a fairness at
work process where you go and make a
complaint about somebody I think recent
reports the last two three years have
said that most internal fairness at work
processes or grievance procedures aren't
effective because it's it's Akin's
remediation where you've got a complaint
someone says oh well that's not quite
right let's not go there it's leaving
victims feeling very dissatisfied they
then become disillusioned then at that
point then they may go to the the
whistleblown process that's that's the
sort of victim that I'm talking about
sort of staff on on staff thank you can
I come chief superintendo I just want to
ask generally about
um
I I took my local police commission
around one of my Village centers last
Friday where we've had a particularly
worrying string of and social behavior
some knife things etc
etc and deliberately exposed her to um
the punters on the street and the most
consistent thing that came up where
people saying when I've reported such
and such
um but nothing's happened or I just
don't bother to board it because the
police don't respond and there was some
some quite cases which I'm aware which I
afforded to the police anyway where
there's been some very serious violence
it's all on CCTV um cameras they can
identify the uh the people the police
will come back say well I'm afraid we
can't take any further um action we
haven't got the results
why not
when it's as simple as as that what has
changed over recent years and we can say
numbers but numbers are going back up
when you have got some clear cases of
clear crime that has been committed and
a good chance of actually identifying
and this one case and it's not isolated
actually having it on on record and the
police say they're not taking any
further action that wouldn't have
happened five years ago ten years ago
would it
so it's disappointing when you know you
share that experience and you know there
would be an expectation that police
would attend incidents we have a grading
system we it's based on threat risk and
harm and something where a crime is
committed and we have evidential lines
of inquiry there would be an expectation
that police officers would pursue those
lines of inquiry
um I mean obviously I can't speak for
that specific case but I also know that
demand within policing and I think Mr
cook also referred to it in certainly
non-crime areas has had a significant
impact on policing resources and every
Force has to prioritize all of the
incidents that are being reported to
them what are those non-crime pressures
that are taking away police crime from
dealing with
a clear Grime so we know from from our
membership that a significant amount is
dealt with around mental health issues
and that could be from using a custody
um place as a place of safety
um which you know we we would all
probably agree that is probably not the
best place for someone that is in crisis
so there are those situations but also
you know we are having to probably
support some of our other public sector
agencies that have also experienced
austerity and have resourcing issues and
implications so and I know there is in
terms of a lack of resourcing
um who are you supporting who's who what
other people's jobs you have to do now
as well so you we know from our members
that certainly some forces are being
asked to support the NHS so in terms of
the ambulance service
um which you know as police officers we
are not trained in terms of paramedics
or any of those issues in terms of the
wait for ambulances in certain areas I'm
not saying across every Force area but
those are challenges that our members
provide information to us about but
equally Social Services
you know in terms of issues around young
people but also within the mental health
system itself
I think I think the committee absolutely
gets the the mental um Health pressures
and the waste of resources when you your
officers take somebody to a e and then
the with a with a Who
've
created
um because of mental illness and uh
problem and then two of them effectively
having to sit there and only waiting all
that time until they get um they get
treated is a huge waste of resources
when they needed enough on the street I
think we absolutely um get that
in terms of the criticism is that you
seem to be doing an awful lot of other
stuff
on minor staff and certainly around
what can be construed as hate speech
which is important but of where there is
less of an immediate threat it might be
said
um
do you think you're spending too much
time doing that rather than attending a
scene of a physical crime that is uh
that has happened of which I've just
given some some examples are there
things you should be doing less of in
order to do more of for what
traditionally people's Z police are
there to do so it goes back to I think
you know we certainly in the service
um we probably require that Clarity of
mission because there are so many things
that the police are now doing which
traditionally they previously didn't
deploy to
um so we do need that Clarity of mission
because we also know the places often
seen as that last resort in terms of
service that they provide so we do need
that Clarity and I think that Clarity
would be welcome across all public
sector organizations as well so we can
work towards a shared common goal which
would result in better outcomes for all
public services we also welcome and I
think Dr Rick mule refers to it as
support from government certainly for
some of those With Private Industry and
for example I would use the examples of
vehicle crime where they can mitigate
against theft and within the business
crime area itself as well obviously the
police will always
attend incidents where there are issues
as you've referred to where people are
using violence or you know instance of
that because that is the role of the
police but we certainly welcome that
Clarity of the mission okay so
Collective Mission Clarity of of purpose
we took the example with the Met
commissioner when he was here a few
weeks ago of the justoff oil protesters
where there's widespread frustration
that more is not being done to
physically remove them sooner from
causing lizards go about their daily
lives the the home sector has provided
some clarity of mission on that one as
the changes to make it clear where the
police should be moving them as a result
of that do you think we're going to see
more just stop oil protesters or type
protesters causing less disruption
because the police are going to move
remove them much more quickly
so I don't think we'll ever you know it
would be I don't think I can anticipate
whether we're going to see more or less
protests
um because that really is not probably
something I can answer well I'm just
concerned with the protests that we are
good to see whether they're more or
fewer of them whether you're going to
deal with them rather more effectively
or your your colleagues are as a result
of what the home sector said
so I think it's important to recognize
that we have to balance with all
incidents of protest the balance the
human rights for people to have that
freedom of expression versus also the
the role of the police to protect
communities prevent serious disruption
whether that's to local communities or
in that example that you refer to as the
the network in terms of the the
transport Network and that disruption to
other businesses so we have to balance
all of those needs when we are dealing
with those incidents and and be
proportionate in our response as well
you don't think the um the Home
Secretary is saying the grounds on which
the police should be removing those
demonstration trips are which are
disproportionate and causing huge chaos
to other people is going to make any
difference to the way the police deal
with just up all type process in the
future
I don't think I'm necessarily saying
that I'm saying that I recognize that
the Home Secretary has given
um additional powers to the police to
deal with them more robustly but it
would be very difficult as I say we
still have to apply the test of
proportionality in all of our dealings I
understand that but Mark Rowley
specifically said that the real problem
over the protesters was the lack of not
the phrase he used but your phrase
Clarity of purpose the home sector is
now provided much greater Clarity of
purpose so I would have had the expected
the police to respond thank you that
means we can now deal more effectively
and speedily where it's appropriate to
do so with those protesters that we've
not been able to because of lack of
clarity of purpose in the law that
you're not saying that so I I would also
I'm not totally familiar with every
aspect of that change in legislation in
terms of the exact detail and I would be
happy to go back and provide a formal
response to you but I would still also
say that regardless of the powers that
the police are invested in in all the
areas of policing that we deal with we
still have to deal with things
proportionately we have to recognize our
obligations under the Human Rights Act
and all of those are considerations of
commanders within public order
situations
thank you Carolyn Harris thank you Chad
um economic crime and fraud is has
exploded and as a victim of it I know
extremely frustrating it is that let me
seems to be able to be do about it do
you feel that your members have the
resource training and as Andy Cocker
said the the financial rewards for
retention and to allow them to tackle
and to specialize in this crime
if it's to me I think we've got certain
officers that hardly trained in economic
common fraud but we always need more
because it's very complex there's joint
Partnerships we need to do with the
banking the financial Industries to make
sure we can get the data right
understand what it means if you go back
many years when we first had um cars and
cash machines you know we were told that
of course you can't have credit card
fraud or it didn't happen because the
banks refused to accept it and we said
it did happen and the problem we have
that organized crime has significant
funds where they can always be one step
ahead they Embrace technology far
quicker than policing so for me the
ideal picture would be that every police
officer has a very good grounding in
understanding the basics of economic um
cyber crime and fraud so they can
understand when that report is made what
that actually means because if you try
to explain high-level crore to most
Frontline police officer go that's not
my skill so I don't understand it I'll
take the basic with Sport Basic report
that might miss out on some of the
fundamentals that are needed for that
specialist investigation down the line
so I'd like to see better training at
the front end
um certainly with what we're having now
but then we perhaps do need more
specialist people as smart smart role he
said he wants to bring in specialist
investigators you can do that as a
civilian but if you want to have police
Powers they have to be a police officer
but of course that costs money if you
look at some of the recent police uplift
program statistics it talks about
recruitment from various sectors the
highest recruitment is from the um the
tourism and Commercial sector but if you
go down right to the bottom three
percent is from the RT sector now if you
need it skills in policing that's the
area you need to invest in but is the
money there to say come from being an
RIT specialist an investigator a data
analyst into policing the funds aren't
there so there needs to be perhaps
proper training within policing as
opposed to bringing in people that are
trying to that level can we do more
across the board but we absolutely don't
need more specialist investigators
question because I need to go into the
chamber what we currently have a 43
model
um police force
I was really surprised to realize that
there was no requirement for those
forces to use the same
um digital system so how fit for the
future is the model
I think if you were designing from
scratch it had one system across every
Police Service in the country because
it's incumbent and we can be communicate
properly and effectively
um those recent reviews done I think
what are Tom wins that said the 43 force
model and its current form isn't fit for
purpose and indeed if you look at how a
director's board is set up and you
should have a board of directors of
probably less than
um less than 10 people when you've got
43 separate Chief constables for their
own operation Independence and budgets
it's incredibly difficult to have that
consistency of of data and programming
across the board there are of course
National Police procurement processes
where you should be becoming things
properly but to force that challenge in
everybody I think it's failed over the
years
I don't know what would be the right
level of how many forces you have I need
if you look at Wales I think Dr Richard
Lewis um has said that ideally he wants
one fourth model in Wales um but that's
not been properly explored but what does
that look like in his Devolution for
Wales
um what's it look like in the United
Kingdom um
again conscious that if I say we reduce
the numbers I'm getting rid of some of
my own chairs and sectors across the
country from regions but I think there's
a better way to be more effective with
unity in buying proper purchasing power
to get an embedded system that we can
use across everybody but of course you
have to train people in that and phase
out the office in the news so it's it's
an easy answer but it's actually more
difficult to implement in reality
thank you thank you Chad thank you Paula
Barker thank you chair
um so Mark Rowley has reportedly said
that uh police officers find a galling
when uh they have to help fill gaps
during public sector strikes when they
can't take action themselves
is that the view of your members
certainly for the members I represented
is because
um recently I've had some anecdotal
accounts sent through from our Branch
chairs and secretaries about police
officers being asked to Ferry victims to
hospitals which that takes them away
from their core function being a police
officer to protect them done and detect
crime of course when they then get to
the hospitals they're sat around for a
long time as with ambulances as um
member Tim allowance already said they
can be sat there in Paris for hours
waiting to be served it was interesting
to note that Jordan need the first
ambulance strike I think end of last
year the local number service in London
was saying that they will wait 45
minutes and then go
um
to me that should have been happening
anyway that you can literally turn up
there's the paperwork and as long as the
patient's stable hand them over but of
course they need the relevant resource
on the receiving side to do that not
least for policing and when we look at
the impacts of other public sectors
taking a strike we're called upon for
Public Safety you know the railway
workers go on strike if you had large
numbers of the public Suddenly at the
relevant train stations that's an extra
burden on police officers to do with
their safety it's right to do that but
it takes us away from what is our core
function of responding to the 999 calls
but also trying to be proactive in how
we can
deter some of the crimes that are taking
place in those very areas so I suppose
galling it's an interesting word
um it's disheartening because of course
we do not have the right to strike as
Crown servants
yeah I mean I you know Steve has stated
we don't have the right to strike and I
actually don't think our members would
want to do that but I absolutely
recognize with the other sectors at the
moment
um however you know we we just want to
make sure we have a really challenging
role as police officers to do and there
is research from the national well-being
service Oscar kilo who have said that
officers throughout their tenure of
policing which could you know span
between 20 and 30 years that they would
experience between 400 and 600 traumatic
incidents that is significantly higher
than most other sectors which would have
single figures and I guess the staff
just want to feel that they are
recognized for the work that they do the
risk that they carry in all of the the
work and the decisions that they make
and that they are renumerated fairly and
the process is fair
thank you and
so sort of carrying on from that in
terms of
um a well-being and Mental Health crisis
in policing
what tangible difference do you think of
the front line review has made so far
or has there been a significant
difference
so we really welcome the Covenant
because well-being because well-being is
really important to all of our members
um and you know for the reasons that
I've just outlined earlier however
things like the blue light framework the
self-assessment we know that whilst it
was introduced in 2019 there are still
some forces who haven't completed that
self-assessment and one of the key
issues from all of our membership is
that consistency across forces that we
have some minimum standards in
Occupational Health across all forces
and that is invested by all forces
because that has an impact on both
well-being you know the number of hours
people then are absent from work due to
sickness so we really welcome
um you know the government in terms of
introducing the Covenant it's just that
consistency across all forces when you
say this is something that was 2019 you
said and some forces haven't introduced
this what's the reason for that or what
what you're hearing about the reasons
for not introducing it so it's been
introduced but it hasn't been not every
force is completed the self-assessment
and we really need to get to that stage
that Baseline so there is that same
level of service that is offered to all
members and all staff across all the
forces and it should be mandated
I suppose that that was my next point
why isn't it mandated because you're
quite writing what you're saying the
lock-on effect you've just you just give
some figures there about you know
a career I can spend 20 30 years some of
the situations that police officers will
come into you know can be extremely
distressing extremely challenging
extremely dangerous
um and that those figures are probably
not comparable to most public sector
workers
um
so why is it not mandated
I think
I'd like to tackle this question of the
day when we talked about exit surveys
and retention and policing
um and the response I got was that was
not for the the Home Secretary or the
police minister to interfere with the
chief constables operation dependence
however as a PC I take a different view
um I'm a I get told by my supervisors
World operation this is what you will do
because it's a hierarchical service
that's what you must do and whilst I
fully respect the chief con Sports
operation Independence to do certain
things
when you're looking at welfare police
officers I think there's some things
that should be mandated absolutely and
in terms of data across the Police
Service you look up Hampshire which is
the assaults on police process which
which which we would like to be um
taken on by every single Chief Constable
because it's a new way of reporting the
thoughts on police if you think every
year we have to provide or chief
constables have to provide data for the
annual data returns it's a very clunky
process and it can miss things if you
adopt this new OP Hampshire process it's
simple to do Frontline supervisor can do
it you can get daily weekly monthly
snapshots of what's happening to your
own officers at the Press of a button
you can file it to the home office very
very quickly so they can provide their
report because normally the adrs it's 12
months historical you submit it you send
six months to process and cleanse the
data you're 18 months behind anyway so
there's some resistance to adopt a new
process it's free it's done on the
Microsoft 365 platform it's been
developed I do not understand why Chiefs
don't embrace it today and do it
properly and it's something we're
pushing for but in terms of other data
you look around
asking Chiefs to say provide a proper
exit server for police officers so we
can understand the real reasons why they
are leaving why can't that be mandated
again the reason was we can't do that
because of operation dependence if it
works for Chiefs to tell me what to do
to a degree why can't the homesick have
the power and certain things to say this
must be done because we all know the
value of data and how important it is if
we can have consistency of responses
across every 43 force in the country we
can then start to make a real difference
understand it because we know the ptsds
on the increased police officers low
moral High fatigue it's the perfect
storm for people as Andy cook has
already said they don't want to come
into policing because it's not a good
place to be
so off the forces were those assessments
are not completed
are you aware of the statistical data
around sickness levels
people leaving for example
is there any data available because what
I'm interested in is of those forces who
are
doing this and you know or exercising
their duty of care to to police officers
and following up on exit strategy access
interviews Etc
um
is the sickness levels lower in those
forces than the forces who are not doing
these these things so I don't have that
data
um in front of me here but again I'm
happy to provide some data to the
committee and it would be probably from
Oscar kilo who have commissioned this
work as opposed to the association
um happy to have that discussion and
then report back to the committee that's
great that'd be really really helpful we
are getting a little short of time is
that okay right Diana but
um
Mr Heart song
I'm very interested in the role that the
police Federation plays behind the
scenes
and the extent to which senior officers
are unwilling to actually suspend people
like David Carrick because they're
concerned that the police Federation
might object to a member being suspended
when there hasn't been
um
case proven because I've seen this in
the past that people in any other public
sector organization would get suspended
when things happen that they're involved
in doesn't happen with the police and
people have always put it to me it's the
police Federation which blocks that
without being rude I wish the police
Federation had that power we don't if
achieved Constable or the deputed
authority wants us to suspend somebody
they can do we have no right to veto
that completely what we will do is try
to make a representation based on the
process that's been followed to make
sure the correct processes are adhered
to the fairness for everybody to stop
vexatious complaints we will make those
representations to the chief Council by
directly or the commissioner or the
appropriate Authority they make the
founder decision on who is suspended
who's restricted and who's returned to
operational Duty so we just make
representations we are not the
determining Authority on that
so you make her representations
the case of Chris Caba who it was a
it was a young man in Stratton who was
killed
by a police officer as far as anybody
knows at Point Blank Range now that
police officer was not initially
suspended he was put on duties where he
wasn't in contact with the public
when his
um
when the senior officers moved to
suspend him what you read about in the
newspapers was the Met Firearms command
was extremely upset and they threatened
to hand in their weapons they were so
upset that one of their colleagues had
been suspended even when someone had
died
um did you hear about anything like that
I did hear about it I read about it I'm
not involving the case of being
appropriate for me to come out on a live
investigation however no but the
Firearms command handing it in their
weapons because somebody's suspended
yeah if I can perhaps correct that with
respect mom um it was the police
officers on the on response Crews that
muted that because of the way he was
suspended they felt it was inappropriate
and were concerned about could it happen
to them the Farm's command itself
supervised officers so it would be um so
197019 or mo19 is now called wouldn't
have any control over how those officers
handed the weapon in their volunteers
and if they felt that the process that
was followed from what they knew was
inappropriate they've right to be
concerned about if there's a suit in the
following day could it happen but I'm
not alive to all the investigation
details or indeed I'm not the Federation
represented so I'm only going on what
I've heard about in the news and from
what you've said there yourself and just
finally with the carrot case one of the
things that people are surprised at was
there were I think nine different
complaints against him over 20 years and
nothing happened I mean clearly you know
he didn't go to court or anything like
that but nine different complaints and
nothing happened would it be the case
that concern about the police Federation
stopped him from being suspended on any
of those occasions it's this issue about
the police Federation clearly defending
its members come what may but it stops
mostly I know you can't take the
ultimate decision but a concern about
what the police Federation will say that
stops senior officers doing what from a
Public's point of view seems the obvious
thing to do
yeah again we just don't have that power
we'll make representations
um about it now again I'll show you
concerns if there's been nine
opportunities that have been missed that
does raise concerns for me because
whenever an allegation is made it goes
into the relevant um police
uh Department of Professional Standards
it's then looked at that's and logged on
what's on a system called Tribune so
it's there so if you can get it used to
be if you've had three complaints of any
type you had a complete intervention
scheme to be looked at that would be
dealt with by at least a Chief Inspector
above to go what are the problems here
again a risk comments on what I don't
know I'm not sure if that has taken
place over that period of time I would
sincerely hope it has
um for me you'd like to think if there's
been at least two or three complaints of
sexual assault or inappropriate behavior
that's looked at and flagged I suppose
the difficulty for the police is that
they might look at an allegation and go
well it's not proven therefore we can
return them but when you've got certain
levels of crime that should be ringing
alarm bells to me about there's a
there's a pattern of behavior here which
is inappropriate and it happens in other
Industries where you look at it it would
be dealt with again
I don't know what hasn't taken place
within the internal system in the
metropolitan police to be honest um I
know that I've had members who've been
picked up for complaints they've been
tracked for the three complaints and
it's been dealt with very effectively
but I don't know what's happened in the
local command from where um the officer
was or what's happened with the
Metropolitan Police Department
Professional Standards
quickly because I'm conscious in the
time what you're saying is that
in your experience it's three complaints
are made that's they're going to be some
sort of action or you know looking at
what would cause three complaints to be
made yeah so it used to be called the
complaint intervention scheme and if you
look at the code of conducts it's very
owners on any police officer it's quite
impactive and I would challenge anybody
people in this room to work to the
police codes misconduct it's incredibly
I won't say impressive but it's there to
make sure you stick to what should be
done properly you get the complaints is
investigated and it might be that three
complaints and they're just completely
you weren't there you were on duty that
can be discounted but it's complaints
that get looked at it's the substantive
complaints that is there a theme of
behavior they should be picked up upon
um I'm assuming the Metropolitan please
don't still do the the three strikes and
you get spoken to you'd like to think
after any complaint there's some
intervention about behavior and
understanding it or not but again it
depends on the victim depends on the
outcome and whether it's a substantive
complaint or whether it's subject status
complaint and absolutely finally it it's
can you show the committee that domestic
violence complaints about domestic
violence are taken as seriously as any
other form of sexual assault
I would sincerely hope so given that
most domestic murders happen by people
that are known to the victim I would
like to think that any crime is taken
seriously within policing obviously you
have to triage the responses but
domestic violence is particularly
pertinent I think there's a port
recently about domestic violence and the
police servicing itself about victims
feeling that they can't afford to speak
and not being dealt with properly again
it goes back to a victim-centered
approach on everybody that report crime
so I sincerely hope it is taken very
seriously thank you can I just ask you
may not know this did anyone did any of
your members report concerns to the
police Federation about David Carroll
I'm not aware of it but but nationally
the probability of England Wales we
wouldn't do without
um that would be perhaps more dealt with
by the Metropolitan Police Federation
which is part of the overall Federation
of 43 40 across the country again I'll
have to ask them a lot okay thank you uh
Marco longy thank you very much can I
thank you for starting your depositions
today with
um an apology because I think victims
deserved an apology
um
and I think not least your colleagues
who also come in to do an honest day's
work day in day out putting themselves
In Harm's Way also deserving a whole an
apology because inevitably people do get
tired of the same dress get that
I'd like to talk a little bit about how
we rebuild Trust
uh clearly there has been a massive
impact uh on the question of trust and
Trust in our police forces
yes trust has been lost because of
what's happened cousins Carrick Etc and
it's not just the Met police
but there's also something about
trusting the police
to turn up when uh unarmed burglary is
taking place
and that doesn't happen and resources
get blamed but actually they turn up and
dance the Macarena with Extinction
rebellion and we talk about human rights
I think you were referring to the human
right to protest what about the human
rights of those people who want to go
about their daily lives unimpeded
um I don't know what it is about police
forces in Europe who don't stand to that
kind of pandering to Echo they're all
members of the echr and Obey human
rights but they don't take the view so
it's about a question of judgment
interpretation and therefore competence
I keep so we talk about
institutionalized
uh misogyny that may or may not be the
case I'm inclined to agree it may be the
case but this is the question of
institutionalized incompetence and
judgment that's failing in the police
force as well
I don't think I think there's you know
very good police officers we certainly
um as Mr cook has referred to it earlier
as well is we do acknowledge there is a
lack of experience in certain areas and
we know that we do have a shortage of
investigative skills within policing
across all the service
incidents that you've referred to today
that your colleague is referred to where
a member of the public is ringing up the
police on a 999 call we would expect a
police force to respond to that I can't
obviously respond to a specific incident
we would like to think that forces do
respond to that I also acknowledge
though there are times where members of
the public are having to wait longer
than we would like them to for a variety
of reasons I don't have any data in
front of me to talk about that I think
when we look at all of those incidents
we do you know the police it goes back
to that mission that Clarity
and there are I mean we've referred to
it earlier today the criminal justice
system we really welcome a whole system
review of the Criminal Justice System we
know from our members and we've referred
to it earlier today that we know that
victims particularly in Crown Court are
having to wait up to two years before
they get to that to their trial and we
also know that some of this has been
compounded not just by kovid but some of
the challenges around capacity
resourcing within the Judiciary
um and though that is information that
our members are providing us the
challenges for that area having
previously worked in criminal justice as
head of a department is that our witness
care units are having to work
um
with victims and to keep victims engaged
for those periods of time it's very
traumatic for a victim to wait that
length of time to get to trial we know
that sometimes they are being warned for
court listings they'll then be warned
all of those are traumatic so there is
uh we really welcome a whole review of
the criminal justice system and it's not
just about policing it's about our other
partners within the Judiciary the crown
prosecution service I know previously
there has been mentioned around some of
the challenges with the additional work
with the attorney general guidance that
has been brought in and I know some of
the those issues are being looked at by
the home office the Home Secretary and
also you're running very short of time
so if you could just shorten your answer
slightly that would be helpful I think
yeah so so we would expect you know I
would expect the police to turn up to
incidents but I recognize that sadly
that has not been the case okay Mr cook
when he was here before when I asked him
the question what needs to change we all
know what needs to change we'd like the
police to get back to basics we'd like
things not to happen the way they have
been happening my point is and when I
was asking about how confident we are
that change will happen is that I'm not
I don't have that Clarity around what
impractical terms is actually going to
bring about change when I pressed him on
that point he said I need to inspect
more the inspector needs to inspect well
okay that doesn't inspire me with
confidence how confident are you that
we're going to get to a stage soon or at
least lay out a path a journey a
direction of travel in which the public
out there can have real trust in the
police and we'll get back to proper
Common Sense policing
I don't think it'd be a quick path to
getting back to confidence and policing
I think some of the steps they can do of
a very practical nature is let's get
back to community-based policing
neighborhood policing putting police
officers out there walking the beat it
was a tried and tested method and it
perhaps hops back to the good old days
of you know Dixon doc green for those
that can remember it uh that used to be
the best option however the demand
completion of change significantly now
um with the types of crime we're
investigating however with a significant
increase in numbers that we want to put
on the front line if you get to speak to
your police officers how many of you
this morning saw a police officers on
the way to work you don't see them
because they're in the police vehicles
driving around responding to Crime I've
long advocated that you have police
officer the the transport Hub so you can
speak to them you can engage with them
we know that section of police stations
have been closed across the country in
recent years because then the public
can't go and engage them the only time
you see a police officer is when you
actually need help and you've dialed 999
or there's a major incident that needs
to change we need to be seen as being
part of the community as I was I started
27 years ago at barking and dagenham I
had the gas go on the state one of the
biggest Estates in Europe of its type
part of my shift pattern was to spend
time there to get to know the community
so when things happen you've got those
community links to build the bridge to
understand I think that will help on one
level that's a very localized level but
you then need
an up rating of skill for National
responses to types of crime
counter-terrorism serious organized
crime of that help provided by the NCAA
but although also incorporating policing
as well because we can't forget that
you've got local crime and National
Crime it needs more numbers when was the
last time the government took a I
suppose a service level agreement with
the amount of public we have now a four
million popular increase population
increase in the last 10 years is the 145
000 police officers enough to deal with
it I suggest it isn't by the fact that
we are failing the public we can't give
the service we want to because we're
constantly responding as opposed to
being proactive certain elements can
National Crime agency can organize crime
hubs can but then that means that crime
is about to take place in the first
place to be investigated we should be
more preventative than ever before but
it's putting boots on the ground to kind
of phrase to get there show the visible
face of policing you can then determine
this way lots of crime going back to
what Minister Abba asked about domestic
violence you can't stop that it's
internal but you can try and prevent it
by being present so people don't feel
safe to commit that type of crime in the
first place
you know I would Echo Steve's sentiments
we do need to reinvest
um in local policing
um because that is the foundation of
policing and I also support Dr Rick
mules report when he refers to there is
that localized level and then that
Regional
um ability to force is to work on more
complex crimes with those specialist
capabilities making sure we have the
investment in the right training of the
staff for those investigative skills and
then there is those National threats
that we are dealing with and we need to
have that model we also need the college
in terms of the standards that they set
the authorized professional practice
that those are mandated and they are
consistent across all four cities and
then there is that inspection through
the hmic FRS thank you thank you very
much could I just ask both of you would
you join the police again if you were 18
or 21 would you still join the police
I absolutely would you know I really
have today have a a really enjoyable
career yes it's had its ups and downs
and every career has but I would welcome
and I would like to see more diversity
within policing right sadly I'd have to
say no I was asked as an interview last
week we were talking about our payment
our service which has been launched and
with the Heavy Hearts I know because the
way they pay the pension the terms and
conditions the pressures on policing are
such that if I say to myself and I
wouldn't I wouldn't encourage my
family's joint at the moment if it
changes and it gets back to being a a
good level of remuneration absolutely it
is vocational it is a calling it's
disappointing to see that historically
policing was undermined if it's not a
long-term career you absolutely need
experience to be able to do the things
you do in policing much like yourselves
you need vast amounts of experience you
can't just bring new people and go
that's going to be happening I have a
real concern for the future that if we
have people if we get to 50 service
under five years in the policing that is
going to have a huge impact because you
need experience we're not focus on
retention but what's to keep me in
policing nothing because in three years
time in our 30-year service I suffer a
pension a pension detriment by staying
on I'll suffer an allowance detriment
there's no point to stay on and with
policing as it is it's not getting
better any time quicker so with a very
heavy hot it would be no
it's a part of our inquiry into policing
priorities and we will be producing a
report and your evidence will be
included in that so thank you so much
for today thank you
thank you
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended